okay I'm here at the Munich security
conference at a pivotal moment in
Ukraine's Fight For Freedom that's why
now is the time to double down on the
support that we provide Ukraine I've
been having meetings with leaders from
the United States and across Europe and
we are united in our determination to
ensure Ukraine succeeds and that Russia
fails and I want everyone to follow our
lead in giving Ukraine that support but
not only do we need to help them win the
war we also need to ensure a lasting
peace and that's something that I've
also been talking to allies about today
you've been talking about Britain
helping and leading the effort to help
Ukraine and one of the examples of
course is training fighter jet Pilots
are you pushing your allies to do the
same thing to train Ukrainian Pilots to
fly Advanced warplanes in my message to
everybody here is to join the UK in
stepping up support to Ukraine to double
down on what we're doing because we're
at a pivotal moment in this conflict
where if we provide Ukraine with the
extra means that they need then they can
turn the tide and liberate their country
that's what I want to see happen and
that's why the UK is doing more we were
the one of the leading countries first
countries provide main battle tanks and
we're the first country to announce that
we will start training Ukrainian pilots
on NATO standard aircraft and providing
long-range weapons all of those are
vital parts of how Ukraine will win this
war and we want everyone to do the same
ukrainians have said they need fighter
jets too as you know we just spoke to
David Petraeus one of the great military
minds of our time he says they're
they're right they will need them to win
to beat Russia they will need fighter
jets and it's just a matter of time I
mean privately that's what allies are
saying isn't it and if that is the case
why not come out and say it in public
well I'm pleased that the United Kingdom
was the first country I announced just a
couple of weeks ago that would be
training Ukrainian pilots on NATO
standard aircraft again that's at UK
demonstrating leadership on this issue
you know these are complicated complex
bits of equipment they do need training
and that's what we are doing and
starting that as early as possible but
what we've also said and I say today is
that we will happily provide assistance
to any country that is able to provide
Ukraine with fighter jets right now the
UK strands ready to support those
countries as well and you've talked
about that with Poland have you in their
migs I said what I've done is say to all
allies that we stand ready to support
them if they can provide fighter jets in
Ukraine now and for our part we're also
leading the world in training Ukrainian
pilots on NATO standard aircraft that's
the right thing to do because this is
about giving Ukraine the means to defend
themselves and win this war that's about
more air defense it's about armored
vehicles it's about long-range weapons
the UK is out in front in all of these
things and it's important that we
continue to do so and Lead because we
all want to see Ukraine succeed and this
Russian aggression go unchecked or to go
completely checked and punished